so for you guys and either of you can go
first like what's your relationship with
scams and give you a scam story you can
just tell me if you hate scams or you
love them it could be anything
very no pressure show for me personally
i have a a very conflicting relationship
with scams because i i'm so fascinated
by them i i love them in a deep dark
masochistic way because the mindset of a
scammer is so interesting to me the
creativity that it takes and the
confidence that they have to have to
pull this stuff off
i don't have that brain so when i hear
about people who do these things
it's very interesting to me and i kind
of love it but at the same time it also
triggers a massive justice complex in me
where i get really mad about it because
i don't like people getting you know you
like justin i like just oh i love it i
love when someone comes on and likes
justice because because this is not the
place for that no it absolutely is i we
love a viewpoint that's like we like
some justice and maybe we'll see some
maybe we won't maybe but i i'm the type
that i'm like okay well if you're
scamming up if you're scamming
corporations i love that that's okay
yeah if you're harming people though i'm
absolutely on your side of like if
they're poor people marginalized people
people who are really like you know
you're ruining their lives that that
upsets me because i'm like come on don't
scare them down scare them up yeah you
know but i love a i love a corporate
espionage kind of scam those you know
you like a ocean's 11 like i'll watch
that documentary i'll support that
narrative
nathan is like the wrong follower nathan
literally comes to set early
and he orders his breakfast the night
before
so it doesn't cause any trouble i don't
want to bog down crafty in the morning
like i know how to be the perfect amount
of late it's like it's not gonna throw
anything off no one's gonna notice on
set i'm not gonna disrespect our crew
and things like that but if you call me
in and i look at the call sheet and i'm
like wait a minute i got a little more
time
i'm gonna take it i moved three minutes
away from paramount so that if i
overslept
which happened once uh you'd still be
there in three minutes yeah
one time i overslept
got a phone call from uh our ad and he
was like oh where are you and i was like
oh i'm in bed and he was like oh you
need to be at work and i was like oh
okay i took a shower like got ready did
everything i was in work at work in 12
minutes
wow that's amazing good for you
i mean
wow yeah see my problem is i'm too far
away for that i have to leave yeah you
got a plan because california's always
on fire you never know when the just
sometimes you'll be driving from san
francisco every day so you got to play i
need that high-speed bullet train real
bad to spam right where's all our
infrastructure america the ghetto
the scams that i'm the most into but
also um dislike the most are like love
scams like when people do stuff on apps
like tender swindler that really got me
like i couldn't stop watching it but i
was furious
i just hate the thought of somebody
going on an app and like pretending
they're
something they totally aren't absolutely
safe space
how dare you do this to me on bumble i
sent you a prompt
i'm not like that i've also been i was
telling nathan i've been swindled um
before by a grandmother oh yes this is
grandma i think i've told you before she
um
she was a very young grandmother and she
had a motorcycle and i was friends with
her daughter and when i went to pick her
daughter up one day she rolled the
motorcycle out to the front yard and
while i was waiting for her daughter to
come out i was like oh what's going on
because she was like shining it up
and she was like i'm just really sad and
i was like why like what's happening and
she was like well like this motorcycle
is my pride and joy
and she was like but um
i have to sell it and she was like i
went on craigslist and the person's
gonna be here any minute to take her
away you know
i know that she did a whole performance
she was like oh miranda's coming okay
we on the bike out yeah give me that
brush
polishing she was so sad and i was just
like oh my god that's horrible like she
was like yeah but she's like i need the
three thousand dollars she's like you
gotta do what you gotta do
and i was just kinda like okay and then
i could tell like she was she was hoping
i would
i mean that's why she was specific she
was like yeah it's crazy she was wiping
the motorcycle with no rags she's just
moving her hand in circles in front of
it she's like yeah it's crazy i gotta
shine it up cause i don't have three
thousand dollars in 68 cents
but i didn't do anything and then later
i just felt really weird like i could
feel something was off and then like a
week later um she was like literally
going around on the motorcycle and i was
in my car and i saw her
damn she was like if only i knew a
former child model
that i could get 3 000.68
that is a good scam though to just like
wheel your motorcycle out like what if
every time someone came over to your
house like no matter who it was you just
wheeled your motorcycle out and you got
out the shining spray and you started i
wouldn't be surprised if she had done
that to more than one people like i
don't think granny i think you should be
cleaning that with windex
she probably just does it on a sliding
scale too when she knows who's coming
over if it's a former child model yeah
you're getting into the four figure sums
but if it's just one of the friends
coming over they only need like three
hundred dollars you know it's just like
shining a lime scooter then she takes
down the steak my pride and joy my baby
how will i get around town as a
grandmother
without my scooter oh man i love that i
feel like you guys have been famous for
a very long time so i think that
you're very ripe for scams i think
people might see you and think you know
dollar signs in their eyes you know
scams yeah i think that's why you
generally have to have a mindset of just
everyone is suss
so you kind of have to when you're still
making bank from a yeast infection
exactly commercial i'm still getting
those residuals from when you're gonna
get these chicks
and you've gotta breathe no you can't
trust anyone that's that's my nest egg
right there i can't let i can't let that
be compromised that's what nathan really
blew up
like we know you monistat
yeah yeah that's me that's me
i still have the overalls
oh